hi I'm Pedro Pascal and these are my
essential essential number one coffee oh
my effing coffee or I like it black like
mine airplane I wouldn't say that I look
for a particular roast I would say
strong roast strong dark black roast in
the morning just in the morning the next
essential would be I guess this guy's
deciding for me toilet don't take my
coffee away can the coffee stay sorry
thank you
toiletries attractive toiletries
basically toothpaste toothbrush and
deodorant sometimes there's a heat wave
and you don't have any seat and you
gotta stay at a friend's house and you
hope that you can brush your teeth and
at least put on deodorant know and get a
black coffee book that looks weathered
and torn and thick with little prints
that people think you're smart but you
don't read [ __ ]
I am reading this it's the magic
mountain by Thomas Monde it's basically
a 706 page book about death all the guys
I know they like to read nonfiction I
like fiction I think the truth is in my
most important relationship my iPad my
iPad goes with me everywhere I will put
scripts in here watch something on
Netflix I will read articles in here by
something on iTunes I will text back
when I can't find my phone cuz it's
smaller than this and it's black and I
can't find it and this is dinging while
my phone somewhere is dinging and so
then I have this and then I just deal
with this this saves the day
it's called tilt to live if I tilt it
towards your direction then oh it'll
kill me take this away cuz you you mean
nothing to me while I have my iPad I
don't need you I need this glasses my
sunglasses
cuz the Sun hurts and then I'm going to
the theater or if I'm driving or if I
want to know who I'm talking to
seeing glasses I have lost one pair so I
have resorted back to a previous pair
that has been chewed up by my dog I had
no choice but to go to the movies and
drive chewed up seeing glasses can tell
it there
they've been chewed up yeah they're kind
of chewed up it's not a style choice
it's just an essential these are salt I
really like salt and these are Oliver
Peoples yeah the dog chewed my auntie
another essential for me are headphones
these are crappy ones I have better ones
far as headphones are concerned I think
is the obvious is to tune people out
tune out the rest of the world I
wouldn't
see 2001 a Space Odyssey this weekend at
the ArcLight and this guy behind me was
talking [ __ ] about the shining and
clearly didn't understand the movie at
all like what are you even doing here
and so I put my headphones on to listen
to music so I wouldn't turn around and
tell them what the hell is wrong with
you
we're great this is a very corrupt
environment I mean who doesn't want to
just have a little cap of crunch what it
means to me is what it means to
everybody is that it's delicious
clunkers like that and it doesn't taste
like what is this taste like a caramel
popcorn childhood butter mother's loving
embrace a German Shepherd in the
backyard what is this [ __ ] this is an
essential that I do not need today but I
have needed in in all days prior this
hat was given to me by a fellow actor
friend on a previous movie and basically
what I'm dealing with is a haircut that
has grown out from like maybe like a job
that happened before a job that's
happening now and so now I just have
like the most unmanageable embarrassing
hair I don't I don't know how to make I
don't know how to do my hair and it
covers my whole head and I don't have to
think about what do I do with this like
mullet mowed lawn haircut thing that's
happening right now he put this one are
we it was that how many was that really
another essential for me which I do not
have is my car da Santos watch did you
mind
drawing it in for me please nope
no it's been much much now bling bling
bling bling bling bling what time is it
the obvious essential my phone is so
that I can you know do what I'm doing
right now like checking my email
checking the time since I can have my
Santos Cartier watch on taking a selfie
oh my gosh ma can I have my hat please
all right and then one final let's extra
edition of essentials I'm wearing them
right now actually my toms they're very
easy to put on they're comfortable it's
not that bad you know when you go to the
airport I go through security a lot and
I really like shoes that come on and off
off and on very very quickly it's like
my biggest thing okay final essential a
clean pair of underwear it doesn't have
to be green it doesn't have to be Hugo
Boss although I enjoy Hugo Boss a clean
pair of underwear kind of hand in hand
with the toiletries you know what I mean
I would say that it keeps it all
together and you know does an itch I
don't model them really but you're gonna
have to ask somebody else how they look
but I enjoy them they're comfortable
they're comfortable that was the easy
number 10 clean underwear
thanks guys for bearing with me and
enduring these 10 essentials of better
Pascal of my sometimes when people say
their name like God we're nothing right
here
[Music]